[Music]
it's seven o'clock you're watching sky
news and a special question and answer
program on the war in ukraine the
headlines the battle for the donbass
starts in earnest with moscow focusing
its efforts along a 300 mile eastern
front
missile attacks continue across the
country as russia captures the first
city in its major new offensive
but the city of mariupol key to russia's
strategy continues to hold out against
heavy attack
[Music]
hello very good evening tonight we hope
to answer as many of your questions as
possible after almost two months now of
war in ukraine coming up in just a
moment i'll be joined by our security
and defense analyst michael clark and
get the latest on the major new
offensive in the donbass but first let's
give you a summary of the rest of
today's news
the prime minister has faced the house
of commons for the first time since
receiving a fine from the metropolitan
police boris johnson took the
opportunity to repeat his apology for
breaking covey lock
it did not occur to me then
or subsequently
that a gathering in the cabinet room
just before a vital meeting on covid
strategy
could amount
to a breach of the
i
rules
that was my
mistake
and i apologize for it
unreservedly
however all three opposition leaders
renewed their call for the prime
minister to go and tonight one senior
tory mp mark harper also called on the
prime minister to resign
the heads of some of the uk's biggest
energy suppliers have worn consumers
bills could become unmanageable without
unprecedented government support the
chief executive of scottish power has
said energy bills could become horrific
in the autumn when the energy price cap
is expected to go up again
the war in ukraine and soaring inflation
are likely to stifle the uk's economic
growth according to the latest forecasts
the international monetary fund says
price rises caused by the invasion have
resulted in surging food and fuel prices
their analysis shows the uk faces the
slowest growth and the highest rate of
inflation of any g7 country by 2023
the home secretary has defended her
controversial decision to send asylum
seekers to rwanda pretty patel told mps
that the plans would deal a major blow
to people smugglers but former prime
minister theresa may questioned the
plan's legitimacy and whether it would
only increase human trafficking
i do not support the removal to rwanda
policy on the grounds of legality
practicality and efficacy but i want to
ask her about one very specific issue i
understand that those who will be
removed will only be young men that
families will not be uh well the home
secretary's shaking her head so i've
obviously misunderstood the policy in
that sense but if it is the case that
families will not be broken up and the
home secretary is nodding does she not
believe and where is her evidence
that this will not simply lead to an
increase in the trafficking of women and
children
well returning to ukraine now a battle
that could decide the outcome of the war
has begun president zelensky has said
ukrainian and russian forces are
engaging along a 300 mile eastern front
marking out the donbas an area made up
of the luhansk and donetsk regions after
failing to capture the capital kiev
russia has pivoted east and began with
missile strikes on several key cities
and today the major new offensive saw
the city of cremina fall to the russians
and our security and defense editor
debra haynes joins us now in kiev
deborah good to see you this evening so
this major new offensive has begun bring
us up to speed with the latest
developments
yes well it's been a a moment that
the ukrainians have been anticipating
given that russia did have that major
rethink in its war it had hoped
initially to attack
ukraine simultaneously from the north
the east and the south
achieving its objective of toppling the
government that was not to be um you'll
remember western officials thought that
it could happen pretty quickly but
actually the ukrainian resistance
managed to withstand that initial um
onslaught by russia to huge costs on
either side but the russian forces then
withdrew from the north from around kyiv
completely going leaving behind absolute
devastation it has to be said and then
regrouping resupplying and refocusing on
the east and yes last night the
ukrainian president declared that this
new russian offensive was underway it's
important to note that the donbass
region has been a war zone for the last
eight years that line of contact that
you talked about has been the dividing
line between russia-backed separatists
and the ukrainian government forces but
of course there is now this huge
intensification of firepower neither
side wants to lose both sides need to
win for ukraine of course this is a
battle of survival yes they won the
battle for kiev but they need to win the
battle for donbass for russia they
fared badly up in the north and so for
them to continue to maintain some kind
of momentum in this war they have to
succeed in the east it means that this
could become incredibly bloody nobody
knows how it will end whether it will
escalate but a new phase of this war
eight weeks
in okay deborah in ukrainian capital
many thanks for that uh well let's get
straight on to your questions now
security and defense analyst professor
michael clark is here great to see you
michael thank you very much for your
time uh this evening so our first
question comes from andy who writes has
russia failed to learn from their
mistakes by launching this new offensive
across such a wide front well i mean
andy's right it is a wide front 350
miles it's nothing compared to the front
they were preparing to launch at the
very beginning of this process where
they were going to launch a north south
uh uh
offensive across basically 800 miles of
of
ukraine north to south um on the other
hand it is a it's it's quite an
ambitious offensive in a smallish area
of the southeast by standards of the
rest of the country have they learned
from their mistakes well we'll see um
their mistakes were
many and various but if i had to to put
them together in one idea it is that
they didn't pursue combined arms warfare
which means working the armor with the
infantry and the armor in the infantry
with the air power
and
this their doctrine said that they do
but they obviously didn't do it it's
what nato armies do all the time and
we're still scratching our heads as to
why
they had this doctrine and ignored it
why they they left the armor by itself
they didn't have infantry with the armor
in sufficient numbers so they couldn't
fan out to actually um give the the
armor some flanking cover so the armor
was was going down roads which could be
easily picked off they didn't integrate
the air with the ground operation
because they didn't control the air all
the basics i mean if i had to say to a
russian general now what should i say go
back to the basics do the basics well
and the numbers you've got should
prevail if you do that that's you know
that's what they need to learn i mean
the biggest mistake really was that they
that putin simply didn't expect the
strength of the resistance yeah that i
mean fundamentally this war was based on
a massive massive miscalculation that he
thought that ukraine somehow would
welcome the russians in at least a third
of ukraine would the eastern third of
ukraine would welcome the russians in
and that they could conduct a lightning
operation and you know if you get the
basic premise wrong then the war is
always going to go wrong and what putin
is now doing he's trying to salvage
something from this mess but he's he's
made such a massive strategic error that
that we will never see russia in the
same light again you know he lied and
lied and lied to the to the whole world
about what his intentions were until the
24th of february when he invaded and so
nobody will ever believe a word he says
again and anyone trying to do deals with
him will simply say well what's the
point of doing a deal with him all you
can do is work with power you have to
show this man or you have to show russia
under his leadership that only power
matters you know
honesty and legality and arrangements
and diplomacy don't work because this
man doesn't do that uh it leads us
nicely on to uh the next question which
comes from davina she says does the new
offensive mean that putin has given up
on controlling uh the whole of ukraine
uh almost certainly not
um and the ukrainian government say that
that they say although kiev is is now a
lot safer than it was
um given half a chance the russians
would try and encircle kiev again and
take it
it may be that the putin feels that he
has to settle this time for some
territorial gain in the donbass if the
world will let him and if the ukrainian
government will agree and we'll see
but undoubtedly the ukrainians have to
work on the assumption that he will try
again i mean he invaded ukraine twice in
2014 once in 2022 if he gets away with
this then they can expect another
invasion in 2024 you don't think he
could carry on from i mean if he has
success in donbass you don't think he
would then carry on this conflict and
try and take kiev again yes i think he
would that's the point if he if he had
success in the donbass it still wouldn't
satisfy him because the argument that
the russians are making is that ukraine
shouldn't exist as an independent state
that ukraine should be a part of russia
as they say historically it always was
which isn't really true but that's what
they say um and the idea that that
um you know putin can be appeased as it
were by agreeing to let him take this
section of ukraine um i think is a very
false idea nobody in the west is giving
much credit to that
as the war goes on they may come around
to it on the assumption that anything
that stops the fighting but the idea
that this would satisfy putin's russia
in relation to ukraine i i think is for
the birds um as long as putin is there
as long as he is in charge of russia
then then ukraine is under threat of
annihilation
it's interesting isn't it because i i
guess many military strategists would
say that what he's actually doing now
with this new offensive is is what he
should have done in the first place yeah
we we thought when we saw all this this
stuff uh developing over uh november
december we could see these these big
forces you know coming together we
thought these are going to be used and
we thought okay well probably he will
try to consolidate the two breakaway
republics in luhansk and donetsk and
maybe he'll try and push them a little
bit further would he try and take mario
paul well well that would be a big step
well maybe we thought maybe he'd be
audacious enough to try to create a land
corridor between the donbas and crimea
that would be massive and i remember
speaking to you know some very senior
british military personnel and some
ex-intelligence personnel who said that
would be a big big step to try to create
this land bridge well in fact he didn't
just wanted to to do that he went for
broke to actually take the whole country
and and we were astonished because it
was such a manifestly stupid thing to
try to do and so here he is now back to
what at the time in december
january we thought was completely
audacious to actually take even more
territory and join up the donbass with
crimea and the danger of course
politically is that western politicians
as they get more and more worried about
this war will urge the ukrainians just
settle for this you know lose a bit of
territory settle for this and i think
it's it's very dangerous because we have
to back whatever the ukrainian
government will live with you know this
is a war that's now about autocracy and
aggression versus liberal democracy and
you know rule of law and so in a way the
war is about more than you just ukraine
now and i hope the ukrainians don't
settle for losing some territory but
then they're the ones doing the fighting
not you and me yeah of course um let's
talk a bit more about the specifics then
of the of this new phase of the war um a
question from neil uh he says how long
do you think it'll be it'll take the
better equip russian military to win uh
oh no sorry uh is that the right
absolutely yeah yeah how long do you
think it'll take uh the better military
to win in the donbass region because of
course now uh their supply lines are uh
right they're right next to their supply
lines and that was a big issue wasn't it
yeah it was yeah the supply lines are
much shorter however um i mean i'd say
people keep asking me this you know how
do i think it's going to go i i'd say
it's 50 50 at the moment it's it's on a
knife edge because both sides have got
their advantages and disadvantages which
you know we can talk about if you want
um but the point is that the russians
are not in a way better equipped
they are they have a lot more they have
a lot more stuff but they're not better
equipped because the ukrainians are now
getting the best of western technologies
that are useful against armored warfare
and the russians now for instance i mean
they are running out of precision-guided
weapons because they can't get the
components because of sanctions they're
not producing any more tanks any any
more t-80s and t-90s the production line
is stopped because they're stuck for
components now the russians have got
about 15 000 tanks in reserve mainly
is this older 1960 model that we see a
lot of
and only about 25 of those 15 000 tanks
are actually combat worthy is that's the
western intelligence estimate and so the
russians are bringing these these
systems forward they're bringing some
pretty old artillery forward and they're
bringing forward new green troops i mean
you know you can replace tanks but you
can't replace a good tank crew who know
what they're doing
so it's not obvious that the russians
are better equipped they're equipped
with much heavy with bigger numbers of
heavier equipment but ukrainians
if the western military aide can get to
them quick enough have the technologies
to counter it and ukrainians are very
well dug in the the ukrainian forces
that are presently about to fight are
about 40 percent of their total forces
um they call that you know the joint
force uh operation as they call it it's
their best 40
they've been fighting in that region for
eight years against the separatist
republics
um claimed republics and they're dug in
and so whereas russian tanks will be on
the horizon the ukrainian tanks are all
dug in so there's hardly anything to see
above ground i mean the turrets are just
literally poking above the above the
ground and you know winkling out an
experienced enemy um can be quite
difficult in that respect also just one
final point the the russians at the
moment are are still pursuing these long
lines of communication um they're still
stuck to the roads they can't fan out i
mean armor comes into its own when it's
able to fan out across a big
front and 60 or 70 tanks move in at once
but 60 or 70 tanks longer road are a
very different proposition yeah because
the terrain of this conflict is going to
be very different from the terrain
the previous fighting which yeah much
more urban warfare this is this is in
the countryside this is tank country
yeah and it's not so far away from kursk
which is you know the famous second goal
battle of kursk which was the biggest
tank battle in history thousands of
thousands of tanks because this is this
is classic tank country
we'll talk more about the hardware um in
a moment we've got another question uh
about that but you you talked about
troops and uh anna has got a question uh
along those lines is there any evidence
of fresh troops joining the new
offensive such as conscripts or troops
from other areas of russia we know that
russian troops already in ukraine have
regrouped but what about um uh backup
from from elsewhere yeah lots of it i
mean there's lots of evidence um because
when they built up these uh 190 odd
thousand troops in the in the exercise
phase of this during december and
january a lot of them were brought the
combined arms armies from siberia and
from the far east so a lot of those
troops came to join the troops in
western russia
and as they've had to feed in more
troops and they've gone for another
round of conscription so they've
conscripted uh last month uh another 134
000 troops there's a high proportion of
them
are ethnic non-russians so tajik
suspects chechens um troops from the
from the eastern regions and
interestingly the bbc did a survey of
the
russian casualties as best it understood
them and it took a survey of a few
thousand russian casualties where they
could identify a person and it turned
out from their survey to sample but it's
quite a big sample that the majority of
troops have become casualties are
non-russian
now that either suggests that perhaps
they're not very good soldiers or
perhaps they were they're being pushed
to the to the front lines and they're in
more vulnerable vulnerable positions we
don't know but there's a lot of evidence
anna that uh the russians are fighting
at the moment with quite a lot of
non-ethnic russian troops in their
forces and again i mean what that means
for morale we can only guess that but
you know the famous phrase of oliver
cromwell you know that's been repeated
in staff colleges around the world for
300 years is a man must know what he
fights for
and love what he knows
and the ukrainians know what they fight
for and they love what they know it's
not obvious that russian forces do yeah
morale is a real issue isn't it
in this war um great question and a
fascinating answer let's get a question
now from alec uh is the dinipro river a
reasonable limit of advance for russian
forces effectively cutting ukraine in
half
yeah
it's what we thought they would do in
the first phases
it's a it was a fallback position we
thought if they can't conquer ukraine as
a whole in the first three or four days
which is the original idea then maybe
they'll go for this big push um
from the south from the crimea up to up
the nipple river so taking nipro right
up to to kiev in the north because the
the nipple river cuts ukraine in two it
doesn't quite cut it in half it cuts it
into a third and two thirds so to the
east of the the nepa river is basically
russia ukraine it's the more
industrialized parts more heavily uh
developed and historically it was part
of russia um to the west of the nepal
river is more agricultural
it's got a lot of new industries in
those in those cities there but that is
traditionally was poland so in a sense
the country naturally could fall into a
one-third historically geographically
demographically pro-russia and a
two-thirds to the west of the uh nipper
river
non-russia more european cosmopolitan
and so on
but
they're a long way from doing that a
very long way from doing that at the
moment and
you know the one-third there's 15
million people east of the nipah river
don't want to be russian i mean the you
know putin's assumption is that the
russians would be welcomed and within
that one-third
i mean about half of of the people in
the cities
are russian speakers some of them are
three-quarters of russian speakers and
in some of the bigger cities like haki
which is the second city mariopol which
is the the great martyr city
actually
well over half the residents are ethnic
russians
and yet they're all ukrainians now does
that surprise you that that this is
beginning um before mario paul is taken
yeah um that's strange isn't it yes it
is it is i mean and mario paul i mean
you know we here we are on day 54 55. um
mario paul should have been taken in the
first couple of days because
you know putin's assumption is that
mario paul is ethnically russian of
course they'll want us there of course
we'll just walk in
and marry apollo's now become the symbol
not just of the fighting but of putin's
huge miscalculation
that they you know they cannot actually
get this group of a thousand five
hundred however many they are in the
steel works to surrender in reality the
russians have got maliopol now they
occupy it they can do what they like on
the surface and they can start to
redeploy troops north which i'm sure
they're going to do but they still have
this issue that they symbolically can't
say that the whole city belongs to them
because of this group who are
underground at the azer style steel
works biggest steel works in europe huge
area yeah plenty of civilians there i
mean it's um you know there's a lot of
civilians are down there with them about
yeah yeah we've seen footage of that
today and finally for this part uh let's
get a question from chris interesting
this because it does play a part what is
the weather like in the donbass region
at the moment and how will it affect
both the russian and ukrainian forces
yeah i keep up with the weather and i
was looking at the weather this week for
slaviansk and mario paul is a bit colder
than it was last week so it's uh 11 12
degrees not 1890 degrees but it's going
up towards 18 19 20 as a the summer
develops and it's it's uh cloudy and wet
there's quite a lot of rain around at
the moment
in terms of armored warfare the two
times to fight in armored warfare in
ukraine or in the winter when it's
frozen or in the summer when it's very
dry and hard and dusty because ukraine
has pretty high you know pretty big
summers
the time not to fight is in the spring
and the autumn where everything goes
soft and that's where we are now we're
in the spring so it's wet it's it's
claggy
that certainly helps the ukrainians who
are dug in i mean it's miserable for
everybody but it helps them a lot more
than it helps the russians and the
russians will have this problem again
that they will not find it easy to
spread out across the fields to use this
good tank country
to its full extent they'll be they'll be
stuck on the roads because you know
these t-72 tanks they weigh about 40
tons and by the time half a dozen t-72s
have gone over a wet field then no other
t-72s or 40 tonnes each can get over
there because it's nothing but mud
that's the problem they face so the
weather is is um uh for the ukrainians
is is
the fact that yeah them for the rest of
the duke wellington's armies you know
they they got rained on tremendously in
spain and just before the battle of
waterloo and you know it it aided their
morale they loved it because they said
we know we fight better in the bad
weather than any of our opponents right
and they always won in bad weather and
they always said wellington always wins
in bad weather became an omen for them
fascinating uh michael don't go away
thank you very much uh for the moment
you're watching a special question and
answer program on the war in ukraine
next we're asking what could have been
on board the moskva when it sat
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
a lot of action going on i'm alex
crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
this is what makes the job
so fantastic
[Applause]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
hello again welcome back to our special
q a on the war in ukraine now before we
uh continue to continue to answer your
questions just want to let you know that
johnny depp the actor is giving evidence
in virginia in his trial with amber
heard now you can watch live coverage in
full of that trial via our website so
that's where you can find that
okay i'm with professor michael clark
and your questions on the war in your
ukraine uh now we've got a question here
from ron michael is it inevitable now
interesting i don't know how we uh
interpret this question but is it
inevitable that russia will engage with
neighboring sovereign states who are
members of nato
yeah i'm not entirely certain what ron
means by engaged because normally when
we say engage we mean diplomacy we mean
you know interact with and i mean the
russians are doing that all the time uh
because that's part of the game of
nations where uh diplomats come and go
in their embassies um i suspect that
what ron might mean is will they as well
come up against members of nato in in a
more conflictual way i suspect that
that's what he means and the point is
that it already is because um the three
baltic states estonia latvia lithuania
and poland in relation to belarus and
russia already have um
very close i mean they all already have
uh borders with russia russia or belarus
in effect and so i mean russia is
already as it were right up against some
nato states um and of course if um
if sweden and finland join nato which
they've said that they will ask to do on
i think the 10th of june and they will
be almost certainly
accepted very quickly then there'll be
an even bigger border uh between nato
states and russia and that really
bothers the russians because as we've
said before in these conversations
putin's got a very
19th century view of 21st century
problems and that's what angela merkel
said about him he's a 19th century
thinker and so he thinks about power and
security with a map in front of him you
know stalin used to use a globe he used
to plan his his campaigns on a huge
globe that was his ambition and putin is
is similar and so he sees territory as
fundamental to security it's not a very
modern way of thinking and so for putin
where where boundaries are drawn really
matters to his sense of security and
insecurity and so yes um one of the
things we're going to have to live with
now from now on because the world is a
different place because of all of this
um and one of the things we're going to
have to live with is the idea that there
is a cold war between uh russia and the
rest of us we're in cold war ii we
didn't ask to be but now we are and
these boundaries between russia and nato
nations will be very sensitive and
they'll be prone to crises and we've got
to get used to that and learn how to
handle them well boundaries um certainly
form part of the next question this
comes from
bobby i think she's referring to crimea
when she says can russia really get away
with claiming yet another part of
ukraine as their own what are the
long-term
geopolitical implications if they do
you've touched on this already but let's
go into a bit more detail good point
bobby actually because the the thing is
we're not we're not just dealing with
the territory which the russians are now
trying to occupy this time round
compared to 2014 it's been done in such
a way that the the gloves are now off
because the russians this is a
completely unprovoked attack there is no
sensible justification for it it's based
on lots of lies and evasions about the
nature of what was happening in the
donbass it was a long campaign that was
building up british and american
intelligence or actually should always
say american and british intelligence
they took the lead on this you know they
they had an idea well a pretty good idea
what was going on going on last october
and they could see from their
intelligence feeds what the plan was and
they've been right in almost every
detail so this isn't just a territorial
grab by putin it's a territorial grab
which has gone so much further
politically than any other one that the
world is now pitched into this
competition and the reason that i feel
quite
serious about it which i am haunted by
the the prospect that this is only the
beginning of a much bigger crisis
is because the rest of the world
a lot of the rest of the world is
waiting to see what happens to us this
is outrageous this is this is hitler
behavior on the part of putin to us
but african states most african states
are just holding back to see what
happens
china is holding back brazil is holding
back i mean all over the world a lot of
a lot of countries are saying
we don't really care who wins you know
for us this is your war not ours and so
the rest of the world does not see this
as a war between you know law-abiding
liberal democracies trying to live as
peacefully as they can they don't always
get it right but they try and these
autocracies china and russia in the lead
who are pushing for a completely new
world order they're trying to revise the
world order that we've had for the last
200 or so years and for that reason
this this war is now a really important
issue because it matters because the
rest of the world is weight is not it's
not on our side not naturally they're
waiting to see what happens
okay uh bobby thank you for that
question let's squeeze this in from uh
chris now this is about russia's
flagship missile carrier which we know
sunk off the coast of ukraine last week
chris asks did the moskva have nuclear
warheads on board when it sunk and does
this pose a problem for russia and
countries nearby uh it may have had uh
it was in i mean these these ships do
carry warheads because the cruise
missiles you see the the tubes there the
four tubes either side uh sorry eight
tubes either side is capable of firing
16 cruise missiles and those cruise
missiles can have either conventional
nuclear warheads they normally of course
they have conventional warheads the
general view is that these um
cruisers
normally carry maybe two nuclear
warheads with them when they go to sea
whether they had them in this case
is not clear i mean i suspect that they
may not have because the crew doesn't
like carrying nuclear warheads because
the extra security involved they're a
nuisance they certainly don't expect to
use them
um so they probably did not have
surface ships don't carry many nuclear
warheads i mean submarines known as the
bombers they can carry 16 or 18 nuclear
warheads but
a conventional submarine might have one
nuclear warhead for its one torpedo this
one nuclear torpedo they might might
have two because any conventional ships
using nuclear warheads they're it's
their own death warrant because once
they they fire a nuclear weapon then
their location is plotted and they'll
get something straight back
um
so for that reason probably two did they
have them on
40 i'd say 40 chance and if they did
have them on and it sunk yes they will
certainly be trying to retrieve them the
problem of nuclear warheads lying at the
bottom of the sea kind of depends on the
depth if they're very deep they're quite
safe in a way because the pressure keeps
it all in if they're not very deep and
the black sea is not as deep as as the
oceans of the atlantic or the pacific
then they can leak so it's not a
question of anything exploding
underwater but toxic leakage it becomes
the issue
so it will rather depend on the depth
and i have i'd say i don't actually know
i haven't checked up on what the depth
was for the area that we think the
moscow went down in um but it will
depend on depth and if if they have lost
them they will certainly be trying to
retrieve them and we will know western
intelligence will know if they're trying
to do that fascinating okay uh we'll
leave it there for the moment you're
watching a special question and answer
program on the war in ukraine next we're
asking what the impact are the potential
use of tactical nuclear weapons could
have on the wall
[Music]
hello again welcome back to our special
q a on the war in ukraine before we
continue answering your questions
another reminder johnny depp is giving
evidence for the very first time in
virginia in that trial with amber heard
you can watch live coverage of the trial
on our website go to news.sky.com
and you can also scan the qr code on
your screen right now and that will take
you straight to our live blog where our
entertainment reporters will bring you
all the latest if you want to watch that
live feed go to our website right now
i'm with professor michael clark and uh
your questions on the war in ukraine
continue andy has a question about the
use of nuclear weapons we were talking
about that ship earlier and whether it
had nuclear weapons on board well this
question if putin resorts to a tactical
nuclear strike what would the response
be from nato and indeed the rest of the
world yeah it would be a massive massive
threshold to cross in explosive terms it
wouldn't be so big i mean a one kiloton
nuclear weapon would cause complete
devastation in a radius of about one and
a half to two kilometers plus radiation
within that area
um
so you're not talking about massive
amounts of destruction
as such if you're talking about small
tactical nuclear weapons but of course
the psychological barrier would have
been broken that you're using nuclear
weapons and of course once you start to
use one at one kiloton then it makes
sense then to go to a 20 kiloton and you
you're on the ladder
um
the uh
bill um burns william burns the cia
director who's a very um carefully
judged man he's very well respected
doesn't speak off the record too much
and he said at the weekend he thought
the russians were contemplating the
possible use of tactical nuclear weapons
but today only a few hours ago sergei
lavrov the foreign minister
uh speaking to
india today i believe ruled it out he
said we have no plans to use nuclear
weapons well you could believe that if
if you know if we want to if we'd like
to
we just don't know that the temptation
to use a one or two kiloton nuclear
weapon for a battlefield objective to
kill everything within a radius of a
couple of kilometers particularly its
armored armored forces dug in
is might be quite high
if that happened then we are in a
different ballgame i mean the world
would have to come off the fence then
about what this is all about and the
nato alliance i'm sure
would
cross a threshold themselves and the
clamour i think would be as dangerous as
it would be
the clamor would be
that we've got to now step in more
directly to stop this
maybe to fight in ukraine not fight
in russia but to fight in ukraine to
stop this happening or to
uh target the whole black sea fleet or
whatever it might be when there is an
irony isn't there michael nuclear
weapons were meant to be the ultimate
way of stopping violence but actually
what russia is doing is using the threat
of nuclear weapons to get away with
whatever it wants yes and that's the
danger that we are self-deterred because
they use nuclear weapons down to a much
lower level than we do and they build it
into their doctrine to use nuclear
weapons on the battlefield which we
don't
um that that threat is being actually
quite effective because we are deterred
from getting too close to that line in
case putin who is emerging he's gone
from you know powerful ruthless man to
an autocrat to a dictator now to
somebody looks like a madman um in in in
global terms um you know we we feel as
if we're playing russian roulette with
this madman and that is this is a kind
of theory about it the madman theory of
politics and that the best way to play
nuclear politics is to appear to be mad
enough to do it and he may he may have
entered that realm at the moment and we
are now self-deterred from getting too
close to that line and i have to say
andy's point is it it it's a it's
it wasn't it didn't seem relevant a
month ago and now it does seem relevant
and that's very very worrying
okay uh let's move on uh to a question
from luiza how does the russian military
know what targets to hit to cause so
many casualties and deaths
well um a lot of the targeting is
is genuinely military
but they don't care whether there are
civilian facilities near it
and then a lot of their targeting is not
very accurate because a lot of what
they've been doing is using their 152
millimeter artillery which is old 1960s
style cold war artillery most pieces
were made in the 1970s 80s and that's
not very accurate either however the
russians also believe as we know from
chechnya and from syria in in
deliberately targeting civilian
facilities
um as part of their strategy to actually
reduce the
sense of resistance in a city and
famously in idlib uh in syria in 2019
with their syrian allies or the allies
of president assad of syria they
targeted 24 hospitals before they began
bombing anything else it was astonishing
and the world sort of shrugged its
shoulders almost
but 24 hospital facilities were the
first targets and those coordinates were
given to them by the aid organizations
who said please respect these hospital
facilities please respect these
coordinates and they use them to bomb
them
so the russians do have this entirely
ruthless idea that if you're going to
take a city
then you have to reduce civilian morale
and the first thing you do is go for the
infrastructure the medical
infrastructure and then you take out the
targets you think you need to take out
and you don't worry too much about
whether they're military or civilians
that's how it really is for example in
the last uh 48 hours in in the viv you
know which has been a city relatively
unscathed where many people have fled to
yeah and of course by sending a missile
in the trunk also sending a strong
message we beat ourselves up in the west
about civilian casualties in afghanistan
and iraq and so we should but the huge
difference is
no western forces i can promise you have
ever gone out to attack civilian
facilities they have sometimes hit
civilian facilities either accidentally
or because they the intelligence was
wrong or because somehow it became
unavoidable or it was a knock-on effect
of something else but the russians do
deliberately attack civilian facilities
the west doesn't and there is no moral
equivalence between the two even though
civilians suffer whenever any of our
forces get involved
okay the next question sort of leads on
from that um it's from marianne is now
not the time to give ukraine the air
capability to assist their defense i
mean they've been calling for us to to
help close the skies as they say right
from the start yeah
what are your thoughts on that
the war in the donbass now this offence
of which is developing is going to be
fundamental to what happens as i said
before you know what happens is
critically important now to the way the
world is going to go in the next 30 or
40 years because the rest of the world
is watching to see who prevails
and my view is that we should give the
ukrainians everything they can handle
give them everything that they can use
usefully
now i think a no-fly zone isn't the way
to do it because it it won't address the
real problems of cruise missiles that
the the uh russians are using or the
artillery which is what's causing most
of the damage um however i think we
should give the ukrainians as much of
the air defense capabilities they need
they've also already got an s 300 system
from slovakia and if they're a more s
300 systems available which there are uh
in eastern europe nato eastern europe
they should be given plus everything we
can provide for them
including i think um the fighter jets
that they can use the mig-21s are the
big symbol of course they're not the
most useful um to what they want they
really need uh su-24s which are the
ground attack aircraft and if we could
provide them with plenty of su-24s um
that would make some difference but my
you know my own sense is this has
reached a point where we should the west
should
because we're crossing threshold after
threshold giving them a bit more of this
and a bit more of that and we're
worrying about it and and going up the
scale as it were
and now it's reaching this critical
point i think give them everything they
can use is my view uh interestingly um
in the last few minutes uh the united
states will send more artillery to
ukraine the uh president uh has been
telling reporters that's following his
call earlier with allied leaders over
russia's invasion asked if the united
states would send more artillery to
ukraine biden said yeah they give them
the the 155s they use the 152
millimeters uh caliber
and nato normally uses the 155s these
are heavy artillery but they're very
good and if you can give them one five
fives they need to get used to the
system because it's a little bit
different to the one five twos but it
wouldn't take long to to master that and
to give them one point
sorry there'll be americans on the
ground training them they will in i
guess in maybe poland or romania yeah
you don't need much training on that if
you can run track this is tracked
artillery so it looks like a tank it's
got a very big gun on it and the 155
millimeter guns are very good they've
got a good range of 20-25 miles it would
outrange russian guns because most
russians are 152s and they've got a
range of about 18 19 miles effectively
um depending on conditions and so on so
if we could give them enough but i mean
the americans transferred i think it was
18 howitzers or said they were
transferring 18 howitzers this week if
that if they go straight into the battle
of the donbass in two or three weeks
time to probably only be three or four
of them still operational because you
just use up this stuff it gets hit it
gets it gets uh um targeted uh and you
know the rate of attrition is huge the
rate of usage in this you know modern
warfare high tempo warfare and we
haven't seen this for years and years
anywhere in the world this high tempo
conventional warfare goes through
equipment like nothing
we've talked about air defenses let's
talk about the sea uh this question from
kamak can international waters be closed
off too so that ships and submarines
could be targeted well uh yes i mean the
black sea can be closed in effect it is
closed off by the uh treaty of montreux
of 1936
which is because turkey um physically
occupies the bosphorus the straits that
lead into the black sea from the eastern
mediterranean so those straits belong to
turkey and in 1936 the treaty mantra
specified that turkey could close the
straits
to warships if there was a conflict
going on in the black sea or it could
close the straits to warships if those
warships posed a threat to turkey itself
it has a responsibility to keep the
straight open for merchant ships or only
to close in very special circumstances
to merchant ships
so the black sea could be closed and in
reality turkey has said they will not
allow any more warships through the the
bosphorus into the black sea but they
will allow warships in the black sea now
to go out again and so as the ukrainians
head after the mosque they say look
there's nothing to stop you leaving the
black sea you can't bring any more in
but you can go out um
the black sea can be closed off and
effectively it is closed off but the
russians are they dominate it they've
got a
fleet there of
you know at least 30 um you know
important ships not capital ships and
other useful ships landing assault craft
and so on and submarines um could they
be targeted well
they could be targeted if the west was
prepared to
to undertake that and you know one of
the things i have wondered about
recently is how bad could this war get
before western forces in the eastern
mediterranean and flying from western
bases
just just took it out i mean
we could we could destroy the black sea
fleet in 24 hours
if the west decided to do that but
uh that would be making war on yeah and
it goes back to what you were saying
before doesn't it it's about where is
that line exactly where is that exactly
okay um thank you for the moment you're
watching a special question and answer
uh session on the war in ukraine next
we're going to be asking what capacity
does ukraine have to launch assaults on
russian soil
[Music]
mark davenan who started the outsiders
project for shelter he's a photographer
he's took some really amazing pictures
of what it's really like to be homeless
um he really just captures it from the
right perspective and i think there's
just
it shows it from the real
raw side of everything
homelessness is just not just about
sleeping on the streets or sleeping
rough it's about being hidden homeless
living in squalor i mean some of mark's
pictures their their accommodation that
have been given by the council and it's
not even fit for them to live in it's
slum accommodation
so i was a child in foster care run away
when i was 13 used to run up the west
end used to think i was big and clever
running away from foster parents
basically i was on the streets from 13
to 24 sleeping off on and off
and then 13 years ago i hit rock bottom
and thought i'd get out of this somehow
i was sitting on piccadilly one day and
i just thought i can't do this sobbed
and i can't even explain it it was like
a divine intervention over the space of
a few weeks i got into a hostel
and the it was a different kind of
hostel like the support network was
different it was a very
um they couldn't they they communicated
which was really well they showed me how
to to feel loved they showed me nurture
you know they they
invested in me all the stuff that i've
been craving for my whole life like love
nurture and encouragement rather than
always being put down and written off
because of my mental health and being a
naughty getting care and stuff like that
so yeah
it was i needed that support network to
be able to show me i do deserve love
say you're walking on the strand or
piccadilly and you see a homeless person
begging
like most of those people they don't
feel like they're a human they don't
feel like they deserve to be spoken to
or anything like that and it's one of
the questions i get a lot asked a lot
when i do the work that i do is what can
i do to help and you know just buy a cup
of coffee sit down drink it with them
and have a conversation you know because
that will mean more to them than a
20-pound note being given to them you
know what i mean so just treat everybody
like humans it's just that like you say
kindness just be kind you know you don't
know why that person's there in the
first place so like if you stop talk you
know you've got veterans on the street
you've got um kids in care on the street
women fleeing violence you know you
don't know who these people are until
you stop and talk to them
welcome back professor michael clark
still with me answering your questions
on the war in ukraine and terry asks do
ukrainian forces have the capability to
fire rockets into russian towns
uh yes they do and they've got their own
cruise missiles um
i think
they almost certainly they won't because
it would be the stupidest thing they
could do
um
ukrainians have played this really
really well so far you know they've
defended their territory they've got the
the rest of the western world on their
side it's a david and goliath struggle
and they're being as honest as they can
be and so on and the and they are wiping
the floor with the russians in
propaganda terms or in information terms
by pointing out the way the russians are
targeting civilians and all the damage
they're doing
if the ukrainians
tried to do the same it would give
russia such an easy ride on the on the
death of civilians and targeting
civilians it would be the single
stupidest thing they could do so yes
they've got some of the capability to do
it and the russians have been um uh
creating accusations that this has been
happening in ukraine saying no of course
if the ukrainians ever substantiated
those accusations by doing it then
they'd lose a huge amount of
international credibility so i think i
could say terry you know yes they can
but no they won't unless they're really
really stupid okay uh very
straightforward answer to that one okay
question from dean now this goes back to
to what we were discussing a bit earlier
and really the effects of this war uh
back in russia um is there any sign that
families of russian service personnel
killed in ukraine are losing trust in
what they are told by the russian
ministry of defence yeah bits and pieces
of it um
arising in two ways that i can see one
is the mosquito was very important
because you know you can't disguise the
loss of a capital ship like that and the
flagship and inevitably the first thing
people think well what happened to the
crew and at the moment only a hundred
nod uh members of the crew there were
550 members of the crew formally only
100 odd have been formally um accounted
for so we're not sure what has happened
to the others and also i mean ammunition
doesn't explode on a ship i mean whether
it's been hit or not ammunition doesn't
explode without killing and hurting a
lot of people on the ship so it's
impossible to believe that there weren't
some casualties maybe quite a lot and
that in itself is is going the rounds in
russia now not just on this sort of
secret internet but also in chat
programs people are saying what happened
you know how do we lose this ship where
are sailors and there are lots of
stories coming out now on twitter of
families saying i haven't heard from my
son he was conscripted onto this ship is
one of them and i haven't heard from him
since you know last week what has
happened so that's one source and the
other source is veterans military
veterans who gossip to each other on
twitter
and in their own private chat rooms
which are you know not that difficult to
monitor to be honest and they're they're
sitting in retirement they're saying i
don't remember happening like this in my
day these troops they don't know you
don't know what they're doing i can't
believe the incompetence and that gets
around as well and so these old
professionals as in any country you know
the old veterans the armchair general
sit around and chew the fat about what's
happening and they've got an awful lot
of fat youtube in this case so it is
it's filtering through however
the fact is that the you know when the
when troops are engaged when russian
troops are engaged of course there's a
rally around the flag sort of effect
nobody wants to see their troops hurt
and killed and they all want to believe
that what they're doing is somehow
important so the kremlin can hang on to
that but i think when that image cracks
i think it will crack quite quickly and
probably quite dramatically yeah talking
of uh images ben has an interesting
question about russia's victory day um
will the war in ukraine end by may the
9th because there has been a lot of talk
about this that whatever happens putin
may well declare victory on that date
yes and may the 9th a victory parade
it's not just a parade with all of all
the uh the weaponry going past the the
stand on red square it's the speeches
yes exactly what they've got
um so it may the ninth will be you know
all of us kremlin watchers will be
watching a lot uh to see what happens on
may the ninth uh will the war no it
won't uh and the ukrainians certainly
are not going to be rolled over in the
donbass anything like before may the 9th
for certain um but putin will claim i'm
sure that the if the objectives have
been achieved they've safeguarded the
russian speakers in the donbass
and that there is still more to go what
i'm what i will be interested in when i
read his speeches or the translations of
his speeches
is whether he is then claiming
that this is only that this now is the
first stage in the big war that nato is
waging on the russian people because
that's the line that it's not really
about ukraine it's about nato's war
against russia which goes back a long
long way
and i think if we see that in his may
the ninth speeches then i think we'll
know quite a lot about what they think
of as the next phase okay we just got
one minute uh left and i want to get
this question in from seb could russia
run out of long-range missiles or
artillery yes to missiles and no to
artillery they've got lots of
artilleries cold war stuff mainly for
these 152s and the 120s that they've got
the artillery pieces missiles yes
because they're struggling with
components and they're not producing as
many missiles they want which is why
they wanted some from china
and it goes back to the old idea we used
to say years ago you know that the any
war in europe come as you are war you
know you have to fight with what you've
got on day one it's not true because now
this war is going on long enough it will
test the industrial capability of russia
to gear up for what could be quite a
long campaign and it tests the western
ability to actually supply um ukraine
with what they need so the come as you
are war is a thing of the past i think
okay and on that point we will leave it
professor michael clark thank you very
much indeed and thank you to for all
your questions fascinating hour
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
you